i discovered van gaal
where did you discover them at the
starwood they were opening up for a
group called the boys who i was really
there to see and as soon as i saw van
halen i went backstage and cornered the
guys they were about to sign with a
yogurt manufacturer and i said don't do
it a yogurt what was he going to do with
a yogurt
he was going to give them money and i
guess they were going to go and use the
money to do whatever but of course he
gave up a piece of what the band is so i
offered to fly them to new york to
electric lady studios and produce their
demo which i did 15 songs
and the arrangements uh and the
performance pretty much winds up being
the first and the second album when you
did those demos did the group pretty
much sound the same on those demos
exactly the same why do you not own that
band then why do you not own a piece of
them i have to tell you that uh i
brought they were assigned to me
exclusively to a man of a thousand faces
in corp one of my companies and i
brought them into uh billacoin our then
manager and the rest of the band and i
said let's do the smart thing let's take
a new band under our wing this is going
to be the next big american band nobody
else believed it so i tore up the
contract and i said guys
love you i'm a big fan go and get them
within two or three weeks they got a
deal at warner brothers and the rest is
history did you kick yourself in the
head many times over that no i'm no
regrets no there's enough money for
everybody right it's more about if you
seeing something that you believe in i
didn't create van halen i can't take
credit for them all i know was that when
you have a gut feeling and it connects
with something i don't know ethereal
bigger than what you are you just away i
was aware i was seeing something big
you